we decided we were gonna uh ding dong
ditch somebody's house
no more than five minutes later we just
heard a voice outside the tent be like
hey guys open up
look i know you guys are trying to have
fun but like you woke up my newborn
and like it really just sucks for me
like we're having a hard time right now
hello and welcome to the roast of your
teenage soft podcast
i am your host your roast coming queen
a girl who unironically had a parental
advisory
explicit content poster on the outside
of her bedroom door
for years elise morales
and with us today we have such a funny
friend he's a comedian and writer who's
named one of variety's top 10
comics to watch and one of jfl's new
faces for 2020
but before all of that he was a graduate
of chillicothe high school it's caleb
hi hello hey how's it going wow
uh i fee i've noticed like as i bring
people in with the name of their high
school
i i feel like that's something that
comedians actually do want
the name of their high school to be said
yes for them to for their high school
graduation to be recognized and for them
as a member of their high school to be
recognized
i feel pretty neutral on it i mean i
feel like um
you know i had fun in school i liked i
liked high school i liked high school a
lot when i was in it and then
i got out and looked back on the way i
behaved in high school and was like
oh boy what were you doing
you know i didn't i definitely did not
know myself
yeah but there's also you're doing what
you had to do to get along
you know making it making it work for
yourself
i think it was on it was on a recent
episode of this podcast i was talking
about how me and my friends used to just
scream at people outside the window of
our car
and we called it oh yeah chaos
hey i always i mean such a big part did
you where are you where are you from
i'm from northern virginia okay were you
in a small town big town what was your
town
like it's it's like outside dc so my
entire neighborhood is like
people who like growing up it was like
people whose parents worked for the bush
administration
like uh arlington or reston
dustin is exactly right it's rested
i've been arrested very very close to
reston
well i i think growing up like um in
like suburbs or even small towns i think
when there's just not a ton to do
a big attraction for like middle school
and high school students is to just be a
public nuisance
it's like a huge like it's a it's a
thing to do you like go to
you go to walmart and like run around
and touch [ __ ] and the employees are
like please get out we
we're at our job
that uh that is so true there was a
uh a shopping center that had literally
like a regular suburban shopping center
so there was a giant supermarket in it
uh and for a period of time there was a
pet store that definitely sold abused
animals
so like for sure of course absolutely we
got our dog there
absolutely someone had chopped his tail
off so like but that's
what's going on well also i
don't know if this was an overlap or not
but when i was in like
late middle school early high school
tour like my friends were driving and i
was maybe starting to drive
there was that trend where you would uh
what was it called like coning where you
would go through mcdonald's and grab the
ice cream cone the wrong way
you don't talk about do you know you
would you would go to
you would go to mcdonald's this was a
trend i swear it's real you would go
through the drive-through and you would
order us uh you'd be like an ice cream
cone please and then
they would make it and then when you go
to the window you would grab it from the
ice cream instead of from the cone
and it would like make a mess and [ __ ]
with the employees who are like
hard-working people who don't need to be
bothered but it was like
such a thing you get ice cream
on ultimately you just get ice cream on
your hand
well it would like get on their hand and
it would also like bother like obviously
it would disturb them because it's
disturbing behavior
but it got to the point where the um the
mcdonald's
in my town um started putting up signs
on the windows that were like
if you order one single ice cream cone
we're putting it in a cup
because they were sick of it they were
like they're like it's over you guys are
done
stop that that is so [ __ ] up for the
poor people who work at mcdonald's
did you ever do it yes i mean yes of
course
and uh and it was awful and i look back
and i'm like god you [ __ ] [ __ ] and
also like i had friends that worked at
mcdonald's
one time my friends and i this is like
middle school though we were um
but you know was like late middle school
we were camping in his yard because we
were you know desperate to have an
experience
and we decided we were gonna uh ding
dong ditch
somebody's house and we just picked like
a random house up the street and we did
it and we ran back to the tent giggling
and we were like oh my god that was such
a
you know however we were and like um
no more than five minutes later um we
just heard a voice outside the tip be
like hey guys
open up and we opened up the tent and it
was the guy who lives there and he was
like
i look i know you guys are trying to
have fun but like you woke up my newborn
and like it really just sucks for me
like we're having a hard time right now
he was like he was like totally like if
he if he would have yelled at us we
would have been like
[ __ ] that guy but because he was just
like look i get it you're bored
but please don't do it again and he was
like defeated
oh why did you guys
choose me couldn't you have chosen
another house
couldn't you have done yeah it just it
the
the decision to like menace the
community that you're in because you're
bored
is so specific to being a teenager you
could like
two more years of life experience and
you start to go
wait that's horrible why would i do that
yeah exactly like we why am i behaving
this way at the grocery store
like it doesn't make sense i would
go to giant i remember it was the thrill
of our life
that the there was this the row of toys
at the grocery store
with the balls they had a barbie that
you could record
on the barbie saying stuff and
anyone could record anyone who picked up
the
box at the bar we could record and every
day my friends and i would record it
saying horrible stuff
and the giant employees would be like
hey you guys are always coming in here
making the barbie say
[ __ ] and stuff
we don't we don't work here really so if
you could just like not make it harder
that'd be dope
yeah exactly they're like you i have to
reprogram all the barbies
every day because you guys keep doing
this and we would just be like
we got really into uh going places like
the bowling alley or walmart or dairy
queen
um and taking pictures with people
we would be like just any any person we
deemed random we would be like
we would be like can we get a picture
with you and they almost always would be
like
yeah i got like they just they didn't
know what to say
and we would do it we were like this was
that was so fun that was so random of us
and it's like what is wrong i mean it's
like mental illness
in the in not in the cool way sickness
and it's it's
uh it's always directed at hourly
workers
and employees like i remember me and my
friends would uh
we would go into abercrombie because we
we were also
hungry and so we would go into
abercrombie and we would go
and we would be like these pants are
ripped
you know right it'd be like there's
always
like why are they ripped they're really
expensive and they're ripped and they
would be like that's the style and we'd
be like what they're ripped
and then like leave
i just i there were so few times like
less than one percent that whoever we
were [ __ ] with would just like lay
into us and be like
stop and i remember those times and they
were correct and i i feel so much worse
for the people who just endured it and
were like
i don't want to get in trouble i'm just
going to deal with these kids like the
horrible horrible thing to have to do
when you're at a job that already
kind of blows yeah we've talked a little
about team caleb and then he seems to be
a
prankster etc but that let's like
let's dive in so what were your what
apart from
uh grabbing mcdonald's ice cream by the
ice cream part and whatever what were
your extracurriculars what was like
what was what was your life about in
your teenage years
oh well you know i actually it's like
this really big
when i think about like being a teenager
i just feel like i have this really big
conflict between like
i i grew up um
[Music]
pretty poor like we didn't have a ton of
money and also
nobody in my family uh really went to
like in my
in my household but in my extended
family a couple people like went to
college right so i was like
i want to go to college i want to get
out of here so there was this knowledge
that like
i had to be extra involved extra good at
school to get out of where i was
um like that's the only way it was going
to happen for me i wasn't a sports
superstar my family couldn't afford to
just send me somewhere to [ __ ] around
and find myself
but then also i hated being told what to
do and i hated following the rules
so like i was this like student council
student government
like extra like hyper involved in
everything competing in like
uh student business competitions and
[ __ ] i was that person
who did like everything under the sun
and like wore suits and [ __ ]
and so embarrassing but then i also was
like constantly getting in trouble for
like
talking back or like uh you know i was
getting in trouble for tweeting i was
in high school getting in trouble for
tweeting jokes because i would tweet
stuff about like
you know i would be an officer in a
student organization and i would tweet a
joke about like
a republican politician and gun control
or something and it wasn't it wasn't
funny it wasn't smart it was just me
being like
you know i don't want to make it seem
like i was some brilliant community i
was an idiot but i was like
experimenting with my beliefs and i
would get in trouble and
my like teachers and stuff would be like
you don't need to be talking about gun
control
you don't you don't know what you're
talking about or i would make jokes like
um i would make jokes about like having
fans
like uh if someone was nice to me at an
event like another student i would be
like oh i love my fans
and i would get in trouble for [ __ ] like
that and it made me so mad
we're like really following you on
twitter too
yeah of course because it was also i was
like um
there were like these there was this
organization called fccla
that um was like uh family career and
community leaders of america
and it was like a it was like homeek uh
but it was
new age homec which is family and
consumer sciences and leadership and
whatever
right right right i remember home equals
called family consumer sciences
right and it was like a new age like um
young leaders in the world thing but it
was like based around the family kind of
i mean it's a little conservative if you
really think about it their headquarters
is
unfortunately is ultimately conservative
conservative
conservative babe if you really get down
to it they re
anytime you see an organization that's
got family in the name you do a little
google you find out
that organization they're talking about
a very specific kind of family huh
yeah and i was like a state and national
officer for that group
so like uh their national headquarters
is in reston that's why i've been there
because i was
okay there we go um but yeah so i like
had all these like um advisors and
teachers who like
i had a public presence like i was like
tweeting about the organization we would
like lobby
politicians for different bills we
needed for funding and [ __ ] so like
i i did there was they had an interest
they had a reason to be keeping
track of that stuff but it was so
fascist and so [ __ ] annoying that
like
i you know wasn't allowed to like
express personal opinions and like
right because you're involved in student
government ultimately
like come on right and like you know so
much of high school is just figuring out
like who you're gonna
be in the world in terms of like
authority and like that was definitely
where i figured out like
oh i'm not gonna be able to do this
forever i can't stand people telling me
what to do i [ __ ] hate it and that's
a bad trait to have honestly it would be
way more useful to be like
i love the rules i love not getting in
trouble but i loved getting in trouble i
was like
it made me feel like uh you know what i
mean like
like i'm doing something i like i didn't
like getting in trouble but i had the
same
authority issue anytime i got sent to
the office it was usually like
number one i either my teacher would be
like you need to go down to the office
or more likely because i was like
kind of friends with the principal
embarrassing he would like
you know they would just tell the
principal and then like someday sometime
in the next day or two he would find me
in the hallway and be like
hey i heard that you were in trouble in
math class you want to tell me what
that's about and i was like oh yeah i
was right and she was wrong and he'd be
like well what if
you know he would like try to be my
friend about it about that
yeah what if i mean i mean he was a nice
i like i still i think he was a a nice
guy but he was always trying to be like
we just kind of uh we need you to be on
board with this part we had like a
lanyard policy that i was always raging
against
um because of shooters yeah you had to
wear your id on a lanyard and if you
were caught for even a second without it
around your neck you got like detention
or some [ __ ]
right and you do have a photo of your
lanyard i believe
and and this is one of my lanyards and
okay this is actually a really telling
image because
number one i was raging against this
policy i was like if i don't have it on
for a
second [ __ ] you like i was like this is
like [ __ ] like this is like
this is like you guys are trying to like
control us and like you know but of
course
i can microchip me dude mike truly
and they also would be like they'll be
like if we don't if we don't see a
lanyard how do we know you're not a
shooter and i'm like
because you've known me my whole [ __ ]
life you know my face what are we doing
with the [ __ ] plastic cards
but so my little way of like trying to
subvert that is to do this stupid face
right like that's so toothless but i
thought i was like really
sticking it to the well and it also
it makes it look like you're more
excited about the lanyard than anybody
right does nothing for anybody and i
like had to also beg the woman taking
the picture i remember this conversation
because
i was like can i do a can i do a goofy
face and she was like i mean
it would be better if you didn't and i
was like well just let me try one and
then i'll do normal and then
she was like fine we did the goofy one
then i was like alright see you later
and i left
i'm like bothering this person taking
the photos again someone who does not
need to be bothered
and yeah this is my senior year of high
school id
it makes me it really does make me laugh
because the impression that it would
give
me is completely different than what you
just said like the impression this gives
me is like person who's so thrilled to
take his lanyard photo
he's trying to make it fun yeah i mean
look was i effective in my political
resistance no
did but in my in my mind i'm like i'm
like okay
we're gonna make this like some like
serious crackdown issue
okay then when you beg me to put on my
lanyard you're gonna have to see this
face
so that's what we have dude i one time i
mean speaking of like toothless protest
i got i remember i was in the cafeteria
and i
had my phone out for like two seconds to
check a text from my mom
and um one of the math teachers at the
school who was a relentless [ __ ]
uh she was just so about the rules which
is her job by the way
um but i i will remember her as a
relentless [ __ ] for it
they can be you can be doing your job
and be a relentless [ __ ]
yeah she wasn't fun about it at all
there were teachers who got me to want
to
they were teachers who were nice to you
and made you want to do the thing they
were
requiring of you and then there were
teachers who did it by force and those
were the worst because i couldn't handle
it
so anyway she came by she saw me on my
phone she was like um
[Music]
she whatever got into some kind of
argument in the end i was like i'm
checking a text from my mom
so if my mom can text me right now i'm
pretty sure i can check it
and she was like do you want uh iss like
in school suspension
and i was like yeah i do
so she gave it to me and during those
like two or three days i got like two or
three days of iss or something
maybe two and i remember being like i am
going to get
more done in these two days than i have
ever done in my and i was like posting
on facebook at the end of the day
because some of my teachers were like
friends with me on facebook
and i remember i was just posting like
um i was posting like
got all of my college scholarship
applications done in iss today
so glad i checked my phone during lunch
this was so productive like
like like trying to be like joke's on
you
[ __ ] you i actually used the time to
apply to college
um the joke's on you i actually use this
time extremely productively
like so stupid and lame but i remember
isn't that the point of in-school
suspension is to force you to like
use your time for productive means
i think so i i guess my my my big
protest of it was
i've i viewed it as them being like you
don't get to see other people today
because they would have you said well
actually i didn't need to because i got
my
[ __ ] books in order because i
actually organized my folders you
[ __ ] freaks
i mean it also looking back on i'm like
that is also
completely lame and weird of them to
like if you're in trouble they put you
in a small room by yourself for the
whole day like
okay prison vibes hate to see that
exactly it's like why are we
modeling like the discipline in a school
off of a prison like why is that
it's like solitary confinement it's like
an exact one for one model of like well
you messed up so you don't get to be in
gen pop anymore
it's like completely [ __ ] up
they feed you like [ __ ] one nasty
chicken wing while you're in there too
and your
throat yeah they throw you a piece of
bread and it's like molded
yeah it's i mean i oh yeah the thing is
i was always getting in trouble for
stuff that they technically
uh had a reason for but i always was
just like
i shouldn't have to follow all of these
rules because
you know who i am it's not a huge school
you know it was like i feel like there's
that flip that switches where you just
realized that or switched that flips but
where you're like this doesn't matter
why does it matter if i check my phone
during lunch
what's gonna happen in the argument i
remember and god i i can't even imagine
what kids are going through now because
now it's so much more a part of life
but the argument was if we let you check
your phone sitting at the cafeteria
table in school
what's stopping into the bathroom and
taking a picture of somebody
uh while they're using the restroom that
was the that was the argument
oh my god and i was like well what's
stopping me is i'm texting my mom
and i'm not a predator like what is
wrong with you guys
stopping me is my internal moral compass
and right a person who's gonna do that
isn't not gonna do it because the school
has a rule about cell phone use
like right it's not like i was like
well i was gonna take a non-consensual
nude image of one of my classmates but
the school has a cell phone policy
so i'm not gonna break that rule i woke
up today and i was feeling like doing
revenge porn
but the school said it wouldn't be cool
so
i'm actually just gonna study and it's
like you're so [ __ ] dumb your rules
suck you're lame
take a roll against taking pictures of
people in the bathroom i guess
right and it was like what if what if
you're like what if that's how bullying
spreads is if you're like all texting at
lunch about somebody i'm like you guys
watch too many movies
truly we like bullying is not like in tv
like even then i was like bullying is
just when we don't invite somebody to
something it's not like we walk up to
them and go like
nice nice bangs [ __ ] or like what i
mean it's like not like that
it's cold especially like when i was a
kid
there was this like moral panic around
the internet
and what we were talking about on our
phones and what we were doing on there
and like
we talked about this on a previous
episode but like what we were getting
off wikipedia
and what we were doing on our phones and
they would
project on to us stuff that it was like
i mean we're mainly just talking about
what we would have been talking about in
person
there was this truly and there was this
like uh when i was in high school yik
yak got really big
do you remember yeah yeah yeah yik yak
was like
the for anyone who doesn't know that's
listening yik yak was like this secret
posting app where you could post like
high schoolers were using it to post
rumors basically and being like caitlyn
s
sucked josh's dick after school or
whatever like it was like the most
heinous [ __ ] in the world
and it's actually so [ __ ] up
it's so [ __ ] up and it like it really
did ruin lives but we had so many
conversations i mean i just feel like we
were getting gaslit all the time by like
the administration of the teachers and
stuff because like
i we would my friend group uh would be
really nice to like the kids who didn't
have like as many friends or so we would
give them rides we would hang out with
them like the kids who were like
who would be considered in like uh you
know 90s movies to like
the the burnouts or whatever like that
dumb old trope
we always went out of our way to be nice
to them because we were like okay we've
gotten anti-bullying messages forever
like we get it like we don't want to be
mean to anybody
but then we started being accused the
teachers started being like
you're bullying them by including them
you're like you're like it's a joke
it's a joke to you that you're being
nice you know what i mean like they
thought
right and i'm like no that's not
actually a thing people do no i was like
we're literally just trying to make sure
that we don't have a
uh an event at the school like we're
we're trying to be nice and do the right
thing and like uh not be
you know a [ __ ] news story and then
they were like no this is a game to you
we were like no you're being too nice
it's suspicious
that's that's completely i
i got in trouble one time for posting a
facebook status because a teacher was
following me where i compare i said
which harry potter character everyone in
my friend group was
and he was like you shouldn't be
comparing people to characters
you know you never know
you shouldn't be you shouldn't be making
comparisons
you shouldn't be reading books i'll
start there don't
read books and then try to apply them to
your life because that's
a slippery slope that you don't want to
go down if i could give you any lesson
in this life
as a student it would be do not use
media to understand yourself and your
position in the world
at all ever that's bad news moral
lessons
from books stop literature stop now
you're gonna you're gonna go down a dark
path
it was really great he like pulled me
into his office and was like you should
not be
comparing people to kids i mean it's
insane i
there was this um there was this we did
this like welcome back to school video
and i was tasked with interviewing the
vice principal who was like the
principal was cool guy the principal at
our school was
like cool guy he was like fun guy the
vice principal was like
you're [ __ ] like he was like mr he was
like mr tough guy mean
mean guy i think maybe that's like the
unspoken
principle to vice principal rule yeah
our principal was like
he was like aloof and you didn't really
see him and our vice principal
like was the guy who actually
disciplined you and was mean
yeah i think the principal role is to be
like i mean it's like that steve buscemi
meme where he's like how do you do
fellow kids like that's the principle
and then the vice principal's like a cop
he's just like
i we caught you on video smoking a
cigarette in your car like it's like
very like his job is to be like the
police and he always has to do this too
he has to go like this
i was tasked for the back to school
video with humanizing him
through an interview because they were
worried that he was like people
all the kids hated him and didn't want
to talk to him because he was scary cop
vibes
okay so you're gonna mark maron him
yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna use
the power of comedy to
endear him to the masses and um
in the video i was like asking like
little cutesy questions being like
is it true that you hate all the kids in
the school like i was like trying to
like
put like get him to be like no it's not
i know you guys think that or whatever
and then i did the video with him
whatever um
and the teacher who was in charge sat me
down like two days later after she
looked over the footage and she was like
i am so embarrassed i am so appalled i
am so disgusted
you you never make a position or someone
who's in a position of authority
play the heavy you never make put them
in that position
and i was like girl we're trying to make
him seem like a human
like we gotta we gotta do something like
it's also an insane lesson you never
speak truth to power never
and i don't like truly she this teacher
is a cool like progressive person and
one of the only ones in the town i think
she was just like
um trying to cover her own ass of like i
can't send kids in there and seem like i
sent them on a mission to make him look
stupid or whatever
don't hold it against her but yeah the
takeaway from that is like someone who's
in power over you should never be
questioned or like
poked fun at and it's like [ __ ] that i
don't like that
and also like it's just such a minor
like
thing to make fun of your self with like
to be like do you really hate all the
kids and him be like no
like that's such a it's easy i know
that's such a truly like
trump on fox news like question
basically
yeah it's so easy it's like it's like
yeah it's like a fox news interview
trump and was like
do you really hate everyone who doesn't
look like you and he'd be like no
you know it's like the simplest like
yeah like
i actually hate me and then i'll be like
yeah it's like the softest like softball
kind of like we're gonna give it to you
hard like fake question
ever yes well anyway i was a great
journalist
then and now yeah he couldn't take the
heat he couldn't handle a real
journalist sitting in his office with a
camera
and that's why you're here and not the
principal and i'm
and i'm this the student journalist
[Laughter]
do you okay what was do you remember the
biggest trouble you ever got
in oh
god i'm trying to decide
there are a couple big troubles i'm
honestly trying to pick the
the biggest trouble um
okay here's one of the big troubles so
i was i was the um
the leader of our like student spirit
group
um uh the chili bomb squad never forget
and uh and then what was it called the
swarm i think eventually we changed the
name because we were the hornets
and um you know so i would like squad is
really good though but i guess
maybe it was what no you know what it
was chile bombsquad was invented by the
people that had already graduated
and when i took over it was a really
good name and i knew that i just wanted
to put my own mark on it
changed the name i mean it was really
psychotic kind of stuff
and then so i changed a good name and
then rebranded i got like a poster made
i got like
no i got like a vinyl like i got new
shirts made i mean i really was like
taking over i was like this is now my
squad
administration yeah there's look there's
a new sheriff in town
and we would like go to all the games
and cheer and like carry flags and like
i will say i don't care about this now
i'm not saying this to pat myself on the
back
we had the best student section in like
our whole district like we went the [ __ ]
off like we were like
at every away game we packed the stands
like at every home game it was like
we were like kind of the [ __ ] like we
were we were doing it
i can't i don't know what to tell you
and so
there was this catholic uh this catholic
private school in our district
um or conference or whatever the [ __ ]
those things were called and
it's crazy how much this used to mean to
me and now i can't even tell you what it
was called
um but they their their school is called
bishop leblanc
and we hated them and i don't really
know why i don't i don't think it was
anti-catholic sentiment but we
definitely did feel like
because they were a private school we
were like those those preppy
like we there definitely was a private
school public school aspect
to it yeah um they i think we're the
only private school in
our like situation like if you went a
step above whatever i'm talking about
there were more of them because it
included the kansas city area
but the people you played most often in
sports they were the only private school
yeah never played the private school
kids so they were all just very
mysterious and sexy to us and we just
assumed
yeah they had drugs and that seemed cool
and this i would say bishop a bond if
anyone that
went or goes to her works at bishop
lebland and st joseph missouri it's not
a good
private school it's like a small like
rinky dink like i can't believe people
are paying to send their kids to it if
i'm honest
um but you know how catholic people are
they love to have uh
well they want to send their kids to one
of they want to send all their kids into
the same building
and that's that's on them right and
that's fine and i will also say if i was
in st joseph missouri and i had to pick
between the public schools there and
this like tiny catholic school that also
isn't great
probably pick the private one because
it's a weird situation going on in the
city so anyway
we have a rivalry with them we go to one
of their games we're completely
disrespectful like as
a cheering section we like we're like
you know we're like [ __ ] we're like
finding out i mean we would do [ __ ]
we would do [ __ ] before games like we
would like search their like
um whoever was playing for their team on
facebook and try to see if they went
through a breakup or something so we
could like chant their ex-boyfriend's
name
like like we would do we would do like
crazy [ __ ] up
yeah like we would do [ __ ] up stuff
and i look back now and i'm like jesus
like i mean we would like try to get
gossip from other people
in their town we'd be like what do you
know about this guy oh he
okay so he he like he he threw up after
one drink at a party
cool and then at the game we would like
chant when he was doing free throws or
something like
you know can't hold his beard like we
would just like do
like [ __ ] that's like it's not cool so
we yes we went to their school
we were playing them in a game of i
think basketball or volleyball or
something
and um we were
super disrespectful to an extent that is
like completely uncalled for and
unacceptable
and it's like truly from like a human
point of view and then when we were
leaving
someone threw glass bottles at us like
what like someone like threw glass at us
and like almost hurt us
so then we were like it's on i think we
were like
so people were people were getting on
facebook and being like because
they had another game against us like
two weeks later at our school
and we had a bigger school and a bigger
and we were like you guys i mean their
school was small anyway so like their
student section even at home games was
like
week and then they were gonna come to
our school where we were like we always
packed up the home games and
people started posting on facebook like
we're gonna [ __ ] you guys up we're gonna
start a brawl during the game we're
gonna like beat you guys up we're gonna
we're gonna meet you at your cars and
cut your tires and i
swear to you i swear to you i i it was
like
the craziest [ __ ] or i will say this is
a possibility too
that's what we were told maybe it wasn't
true but that's what we were told by the
administrations
and it was so like crazy i mean i
remember i had to like three
every day for like three or four days
before the game i had to sit down with
the principal and be like
him be like what are you doing to make
sure this doesn't get out of control and
me being like i am 17.
and that was like we had these
conversations then the game happened
it was very like rowdy and definitely
disrespectful the chants were a little
uncalled for
no one ended up getting physically hurt
there definitely was some like yelling
at each other in the parking lot kind of
vibes
um if i remember correctly but i
remember definitely having a lot of
private conversations with my principal
that week about like
you need to tone down the rhetoric you
need to be a leader
and me being like again i cannot legally
vote yet
right i don't know i cannot be in charge
of this
yeah it was nuts seems like
the adults should really be dealing with
somebody should be reigning this in and
it can't be me because i am in it
you know and i'm i have to maintain my
street cred
yeah exactly you're actually like kind
of making me an ark right now
and that's not yeah you're turning me
into like a criminal informant and i'm
like in it i can't be part of this
i feel like when i um
because you're the same age as my
younger sister so i'm 30 so just like
when i was
getting into high school facebook was
such an unknown quantity that like they
didn't know what to do about it
at all so there was like there was a
scandal at my school where
there was a group project in this uh
i remember the teacher the prince the
teacher whose classes
was named mr waxman because everyone
called it waxman gate
and i love it i love it i love it
uh he like had some big assignment that
you were like allowed to work on in
groups and one
and a bunch of people formed a big group
on facebook to work on it instead of
working
on it physically in person and a parent
printed out the group and brought it to
the school and all of them got in
trouble for cheating and the kid who
started the group had his college
admissions
rescinded no it's not cheating
they were just working online
they're just doing what now is legally
required in like every state
for students to do dude i mean
that sucks so bad because it really is
just like
you were just doing the thing i mean i
know what cheating looks like i did it a
lot
and that's not cheating yeah it's no
it's not people everyone was
contributing answers in the group
like everyone like in order to be in the
group you had to contribute it was just
doing what they were supposed to be
doing in person online
and a parent printed it out what kind of
a psycho
let's look at some of these photos that
you have sent
us okay i think that i think they're
going to help round out this picture so
i wanted to start with this one
what are we looking at yeah yeah i
thought you would have some questions
about this so i try
i try to include evocative provocative
sort of so what you have here is um for
those of you who don't know that little
pin on my chest is in the shape of
missouri
um i believe
i'm trying to figure out what point we
were thinking of here um
oh this is state so okay so i was i was
the state president from missouri of
this or student organization
and you can see next to me there's like
um that guy's from ffa which is the
future farmers of america like the ag
group right and
this guy below is maybe deca and then
the guy um
below and to the other side is maybe
like fbla the business leaders
so this is me dressed up in my official
uniform that is
um a blue tie with um the united states
uh flags all over it that was part of
our uniform
and um when you were the state president
um or national officer of one of these
organizations they would hang your
picture up in the state capitol
so this is me in the state capitol
uh taking a picture presumably for like
my mom
um of me with my picture on the wall in
the state capitol
being like look how important i am and
you're
and so this is the outfit you had to
wear when you were doing anything in
your
official capacity this like
like the red suit jacket and the tie and
everything
yeah so it's and it's very specific too
uh like
uh women had a very specific uniform and
men had a very specific uniform
disgusting and then like it was a big i
remember it was a big argument in the
organization around whether
um women uh should be allowed to wear
girls really truly girls should be
allowed to wear
pants and flats because historically
they had always been required to wear
skirts and heels
um so it was a big fight about that um
but yeah there's a there's a gold pin on
one side and then your state
name tag on the other side uh white
oxford shirt with like a red
with red white and blue tie of some kind
we had like six different um
regulation ties and then black dress
pants black dress socks and black
dress shoes see and it seems now it
seems like because you're next to all
these other
like presidents it seems like you guys
have the flashiest
ensemble of the other president
absolutely we have the flashiest
ensemble and um
it definitely was a situation where like
but here's the thing
ffa has such better branding because
they required every single member to
have a jacket and ours was only for
officers
so it kind of was bad branding on
my group's uh decision but these groups
were all started in like the 50s
um so you know they didn't know couldn't
be a group unless there was a jacket
truly it was like yeah it was like such
a thing to be like okay we're gonna be
the homet girls and we're gonna wear red
jackets and it was all
women when it started so you know it
goes like that sometimes
well i think that i i think it makes you
guys look way more fun
and the rest of them look boring we were
absolutely more fun i mean i will say
ffa bigger flashier organization but
ultimately about farming um you know
and they will say it's not just about
farming but i will say that wrong
and we were the most importantly for the
farming yeah it's mostly for the farming
and i was in that too but i just didn't
care about it as much
all right let's look at this next photo
okay
here are you but here's here you are at
mcdonald's
yes have you pranked anyone prior to
this photo
you know i would have at this time
considered what i'm doing to be a prank
um so basically what you're looking at
here is
this is the mcdonald's in my uh hometown
um
the ronald statue on the bench outside
was a pretty cool thing that we had that
not every mcdonald's
has as you might know and we would go
there cause trouble you know definitely
at this point i couldn't drive so one
you can see i'm wearing ripped jeans
intentionally
um call back to your oh your jeans are
wet new jeans are ripped did you buy
them like that
why um
and we one of my older friends
definitely drove us to mcdonald's
we had some food we were way too loud in
the restaurant for no reason at all
and then you know on the way out we were
like desperate for something to do so of
course i was like
what if i took a picture pretending to
give ronald a drink
and everyone was dying funniest thing
we've ever heard absolutely
abs well i mean to even have that statue
outside
of your mcdonald's is to invite
teenagers
to take all kinds of pictures with it
it's a gift and i do have several other
pictures by the way when i was looking
for pictures to send you i had to decide
which ronald mcdonald picture i would
send you because this was such a i was
definitely
i wasn't like uh ever thinking i would
be a comedian at this time in my life
but if i found something that made
people laugh i would do it
17 times i was like these pictures like
going right on facebook
like oh straight to facebook like like
you take it on someone's
take it on someone's cell phone or in
this case i guess maybe this was a night
that we had a um
what sometimes we would we thought it
was really retro and funny to have
um polaroid not not polaroids but
disposable
a disposable camera yes we thought that
was fun like that was a night for us as
we would get a disposable camera and go
around town and be like what crazy
pictures can we get
um but yeah it was definitely
immediately uploaded to facebook in the
mobile uploads section
no um no deleting any of just
all of them uploaded it and then
everyone can see
100 photos of this yeah and then like us
laying in the grass laughing or
something you know
and i'm wearing a wristband there so
this might have been um
this might have been before after or
during a like christian youth conference
that was hosted in my town
um we got wristbands for those so this
might have been during um some some
christian fun
well okay okay and were you like
did you troublemake during your
christian fun or were you
respectful when it's like the lord's
time
no we trouble made during christian time
but not in a like there were definitely
like when
when they started playing certain songs
you knew it was time to like somber up
and cry a little bit and like raise your
hands and like really worship
yeah all the other times i mean my youth
group was cool they would play clips
from the office and we would have like
ipad giveaways and all kinds of [ __ ]
like that so it was definitely
troublemaking was encouraged as long as
it was like
um not blasphemous jesus
was a troublemaker jesus made good
trouble yeah jesus made good trouble
that was part of his whole deal
his followers have made some bad trouble
but jesus was primarily
in the good trouble business he was
yeah he was doing good in a way that it
was positive but yeah
he had good ideas they've been taken in
some really interesting directions but
he had good ideas
yeah i was thinking as you were
describing like
uh the the violence that almost erupted
at your game that like
if only the capital had taken the same
steps to prevent
violence right someone should have been
sitting them down and being like hey
this needs to be we need to cool
off we needed a principal and a caleb to
be meeting up and being like hey who's
who's in charge of making sure this
doesn't get crazy because i've seen some
stuff on facebook that says it's going
to get crazy
we've been reading the facebook post and
it's not looking good i will say
broken threats on the facebook post yeah
sort of uh people are talking about
execution so maybe it's time to sit
people down in the principal's office
but hey maybe next time okay let's look
at this next photo
okay more fun with statues yeah
really uh and i actually will be honest
with you this is outside of another
mcdonald's
okay so really anytime i could find the
statue at a mcdonald's i was really
trying to do a bit
now what am i i picked this one because
it
it does display my love of doing bits at
mcdonald's uh this is in chicago
um the first time i'd ever been to
chicago this picture was taken we went
for a student
leadership conference um and this was
one of our nights that we got to like
walk around the city and like see the
world
the best when you're a teenager and you
go on a trip and you have like
even like two hours like my my drama
group would go we would do like a new
york trip and we would have two hours to
get dinner at like
hard rock cafe yeah i love it so much
yeah or like the star diner or whatever
the one where they sing
um yeah so what you're looking at here
is actually a pretty typical outfit for
me at that time
i'm wearing high top nikes with a strap
that i refuse to strap
um i'm wearing tall black nike socks
um i'm wearing blue nike shorts with
black and white stripes on the side very
very sporty very um
i am heterosexual and you can't prove
otherwise and then i'm wearing a tap
out fighting t-shirt uh i've never
watched ufc or
mma or anything um but i felt
that's an i am heterosexual projection i
am i am straight good luck proving
otherwise yeah that's the that's the
vibe we're going for here
um now what's on my head this is a hat
from ed de bevex a famous
uh now closed restaurant in chicago
where the um servers were mean to you
that's where we chose to go for dinner
oh right right and where they mean to
you and were you like
oh they were mean to me and i could not
handle it like like like
like the the woman i remember what she
looks like because it was such a
wild experience to me i'm like we're in
this big city i've never been to a city
that big in my life at this point
and i was like we're in this big city in
this like she like
she was a heavier set woman blonde and
had like tons of like gaudy makeup on
and like
um was like falling out of her top she
was like very sexy
and she was like coming over the table
and being like you fat one what do you
want
and i was like i i coke like i
i could not you're like you're talking
about things that i haven't even
admitted to
myself yet right it's so disorienting i
think she made a joke about me having a
boyfriend at one point and i was like
and it wasn't mean-spirited like it was
funny and she was good at her job but i
was like
people don't talk to you like especially
coming from a small town in the midwest
it was like
i mean it felt like someone was trying
to kill me
[Laughter]
i was like you have a gun and you want
to hurt me yeah you're harming me
yeah so this is me this is me um i
thought oh god wouldn't it be funny her
hand is out
just so that i could pretend we're
dancing and
um i forced my teacher to take a picture
of me and the other kids i thought would
laugh but they simply were not paying
attention so
that's what we have here you know you
win some you lose them you post that on
facebook
maybe you get a couple laughs you want
you win some you lose most when you play
these kind of games
when you're begging for attention you
you lose most
yeah play stupid games win stupid prizes
etc
and i will i will tell you also
something else interesting is um
so this is the first time i've ever been
in chicago flash forward several years
later after college i lived in chicago
and um i thought a guy was flirting with
me when he asked me if i wanted to
um rent bicycles and bike from the north
side of chicago
all the way downtown and find somewhere
to eat i thought that was a date
so we did that that's a five mile bike
ride
and i'm not athletic so we biked all the
way downtown
and uh the first place we saw that we
thought would be funny to eat
was this exact mcdonald's and it became
pretty clear during the conversation
that we were in fact not on a date but
we're just friends
so um and then you just have a bike yeah
and now you have a bike in your downtown
and i biked home i did back home
and um alone because he had somewhere
else to be so it's really full circle
with this mcdonald's and
my story yeah wow this statue has seen
you in so many different
uh places i don't even i i didn't even
think about it at the time but i wonder
if that statue is still there i don't
know if it was
when i was last there or not but chicago
beautiful if it was gone
i know i hope they give it to me if they
get rid of it actually
oh i'm sure it's an influential person
of the um
world or something or rock and roll but
it's definitely a
you know a parent with a child who's
clinging to their leg
and i'm i'm not sure the symbolism did
it belong to the mcdonald's or was it
just near the mcdonald's
i'm not sure i i bet it did because i'm
sure they own that whole lot you know
that's how mcdonald's makes their money
property
so i'm sure they own that so they they
either rented it from somebody or
they they own that statue i do not know
what it means okay well if anyone
knows dm me shout out let us know
um in the comments okay
uh all right we are nearing the end here
so uh one thing oh this is the quiznos
thing
oh my god the meats no
not at all this is scary i hate this so
this is what i think
this was a horrible thing i hate it
and we don't need to get into it but you
can google that at another time and it's
really going to upset you but that's the
christmas commercial
i hate it thank you so much for sharing
um
okay so uh we like to end every episode
of the podcast with this question
which is if you could talk to teen
caleb today what would you tell him
oh gosh um i would tell him
you don't have to be so worried about
people liking you you're not gonna be a
lawyer give it up
um you're still gonna have friends when
you come out of the closet
and uh your life is gonna be so much
better for it so please stop trying to
be straight
and also um
[Music]
don't like i i wish i could if i could
like go back in time i would be like
stop trying stop wanting to be out of
here so bad like stop trying to like be
in the next thing so bad because it is
going to come
and then that's going to be over and
you're going to be in the next thing and
the next thing and it's just going to
it starts to go really fast so you
should stop wanting to be out of here so
bad because
um even though i don't identify with
like
that person anymore like 17 18 year old
me
i mean i'm it's so much a part of who i
am now because i like it was trial and
error so i'm like
i would just tell him like keep doing
what you're doing don't worry about if
you're cool or if this is gonna turn out
the right way
um because you're gonna turn you're
gonna be an icon and
um you're really hot also
that's beautiful that's so beautiful
it's so beautiful thank you so much for
coming on the show
it was wonderful chatting with you and
for everyone listening at home
this has been the roast of your teenage
self podcast
you